okay Paul Manafort remember that trump
tower meeting with Donald Trump jr. and
Paul Manafort and Jared Kushner and the
Russian lawyer Natalia vessel Mnet's
kaya and a Russian translator and I
don't even know who else was in there at
this point we now have learned about the
notes that Paul Manafort Trump's former
campaign chairman the notes that
Manafort took during that meeting and in
those notes there were references to
political contributions near a reference
to the Republican National Committee
mana forts notes were typed on a
smartphone and they were described by a
source that was briefed on the matter as
cryptic they've since been turned over
to the House and Senate intelligence
committees as well as the special
counsel robert muller for his
investigation and again the notes taken
at that meeting with the russian lawyer
and trump tower by Paul Manafort
referenced political contributions and
the Republican National Committee why is
this relevant it's relevant for many
reasons number one we were told that at
that meeting the only thing discussed
was Russian adoptions so if only Russian
adoptions were discussed why would Paul
Manafort have taken notes that reference
political contributions and the
Republican National Committee secondly
why would Paul Manafort have notes at
all if this meeting was one in which
absolutely nothing of note took place as
Donald Trump jr. has insisted time and
time again here are the two different
things that Donald Trump jr. said about
Paul Mann affords presence during that
bizarre interview with Sean Hannity
after that story broke here is part one
you know I think it became pretty
apparent to you know Jared and Paul who
I think Jared left after a few minutes
Paul got is he phone yeah yeah we were
all begin Donald Trump jr. talking about
Paul mana for its involvement in that
meeting um and Jared left after five or
ten yes like she said and Paul Manafort
was on his on his own the whole time
pretty much pretty much listen like I
said he was noting a pretty apparent
that this was not what we were in there
talking about so we mean I don't even
know where to start with this right
there's so many questions number one
again political contributions in RNC in
a meeting with a foreign a someone
involved with a foreign card
it is illegal for foreigners to donate
to American elections that's not really
the news here okay
the news is mana for took notes if this
was a non meeting if there was nothing
here if mana fort wasn't paying
attention why are there notes about the
RNC and political contributions and
Donald Trump jr. Pat claimed that the
meeting was insignificant citing mana
fort was just on the phone the entire
time it appears mana fort was on the
phone the entire time taking relatively
detailed notes about what was going on
at that meeting
certainly Donald Trump jr. said that
Paul Manafort was on his phone the whole
time in a effort to try to make him look
disconnected or disinterested in what
was going on in the meeting but in
reality he could just be trying to
deceive that fox news audience because I
got the impression that Paul Manafort
was you know playing Angry Birds or
words with friends the whole time but
maybe he was just taking detailed notes
of the entire encounter you know what's
interesting that what Donald Trump jr.
said to Hannity it appears as though at
least with regards to Paul Manafort it
was sort of the letter of it was true
manna fort was on his phone the entire
time of course that wasn't a sign that
he wasn't paying attention it was a sign
that it was significant enough for him
to take notes he also mentioned Jared
left after just a few minutes
referencing Jared Kushner it's also
possible that that's true but not that
Jared Kushner left because the meeting
was insignificant rather he left because
he thought I don't want to be implicated
in what's going on here or I want to go
and tell Donald Trump senior immediately
about what it is that's going on we're
very quickly learning and in reviewing
by the way I watch that entire Donald
Trump junior Sean Hannity interview
again yesterday preparing for the
segment he had a list of his own notes
in front of him and very often when
Hannity was asking him a question he
would be looking down at his notes we
have to assume that he was very
specifically prepared for that interview
and the words were chosen very carefully
Paul Manafort was on his phone the
entire time Jared Kushner left after
just a few minutes meant to give an
impression of insignificance when in
reality those actions by the two of them
might have been more reflective of the
seriousness of the meeting maybe we will
find out one day I really think that if
there were eight plus people in that
meeting you can find someone who can
corroborate a story that damages Paul
Manafort I mean many of those people in
that meeting were Russians so that could
be hard to find but if
was going to do it's gonna be Robert
Muller yes and we are still of course
waiting to see how Robert Muller is
handling each additional piece of
information that surfaces with regard to
those meetings and the investigation and
everything else that we've been talking
about discuss this with us on our reddit
discussion forum at david pakman.com
slash our EDD IT next the myth of the
violent left I'm thrilled to tell you
that today's episode of the show is made
possible in part by taga dabbe the
hosting specialists offering dedicated
virtual private and cloud server
solutions as well as custom server
solutions for whatever business or
project you have taga dabs web hosting
services support a very wide range of
customers and businesses that includes
bloggers tech startups financial traders
gamers web developers it's a very very
long list they've got a user-friendly
interface they have absolutely fantastic
technical support over 70% of their
business comes from repeat orders and
recommendations from existing customers
you can get a 20 British Pound discount
off of a cloud server account with taga
DAB
but you've got to know how to access
that and the way you access it is by
going to signup tag a DAB comm /td PS
and using the coupon code TDPS
20 this is a great way to get great
hosting for your project business or
service and support the David Pakman
show
and support our advertisers that sign up
taga dab comm slashed edps that's ta ga
da b and then the discount code is TDPS
20